do you have a relationship with
President Trump have you know I've known
President Trump since about late 1979 or
sometime in the early 80s I knew him in
New York never a close friend but would
see him yep he was generally
complimentary about my work yeah he you
know he was trying to be in addition to
a big-time real estate builder he wanted
to be a celebrity which he made himself
yeah so I didn't know him however I ran
a story on 60 minutes to in either 1999
or 2000 about his campaign for president
at that time right which was basically
designed to sell golf courses
memberships and condominiums right oh he
didn't like the piece he called me and
told me in no uncertain terms that he
thought it was unfair and that's the
last time I've talked to him right
are you going to send him this book well
I you know I thought about that what
we've been told that he doesn't much of
a reader there is an audio version
[Applause]
you